while it is certainly no secret that the
cost of rent all across the valley is
really high and for some paying rent
means sacrificing other basic
necessities so tonight we begin our rent
crisis Series where we're going to be
taking a deep dive into this issue
Christian Gossett has spoke to one
single mother who says she's struggling
to pay her high rent
I've had to make decisions between
eating and Pam rent my car note
or being on a bus Tamisha Jones says the
high cost of rent in the valley is
becoming a harder struggle to overcome
every month that's what we want we want
you just to help we don't ask you for
handouts but what happens when you get
behind some people have no hope
and they're hopeless Jones says her
rants for her two-bedroom apartment is
15.55 for a six-month lease her renewal
came with an increase of a hundred
dollars plus utilities pushing her total
to eighteen hundred dollars we are
really making some hard decisions
according to rent.com the national
average for a two bedroom is about
twenty one hundred dollars in Las Vegas
that price is estimated at 21.34 a high
cost for thousands of residents but help
is available sometimes nine to ten
months of rent assistance
and then kind of bringing them back to a
current status Patricia Kelly is with
hopelink of Southern Nevada a non-profit
organization dedicated to helping
residents struggling not only with rent
but also to find employment and even
food assistance everything kind of just
has a it's been having a ripple effect
inflation has caused a lot of people to
not be able to afford the rent I mean
we're looking at rents that are you know
2 000 which was normally maybe a year
ago maybe 1500 that monthly rent payment
is a difficult task according to this
single mother who tells us she doesn't
know how long she can keep it up even if
you want to move where are you going
you're out price
hopelink of Southern Nevada also
recommends that you call 2-1-1 if you
need more help and that will get you in
touch with the program in the Nevada
Department of Health and Human Services
which is committed to connecting
residents with the services that they
need